you heard that right disney villains
have kids
and who exactly are your parents evie
the descendants have been anything but
shy when it comes to mashing all of our
favorite disney villains and heroes into
the same world
not to mention getting to see the next
generation mingle is actually pretty
epic but there are still some major
questions that have not been answered in
the past three films
one big one being who exactly is evie's
dad
you would think that there'd be some
more backstory on one of the most
important characters
well we dug a little deeper into the
films and inner workings of the fandom
and may have found the answers you're
looking for
evie evil queen's daughter
evie beautiful vain at least in the
first film and daughter of snow white's
notorious villain the evil queen
because of her mother's former evil
doings she was born and raised on the
isle of the lost alongside other
villains and their children
but besides being vain evie wasn't much
of a villain herself
we see that even more once she heads off
to auradon prep
alongside mal carlos and jay while her
intentions on the outside are to steal
the magic fairy godmother's wand that
will once again allow villains to mingle
with the rest of the world
deep down she just wants to live the
regular teen life she was deprived of
growing up
how many rooms in your castle oh too
many to count
while growing up on the isle evie was
always a welcome distraction to the
chaos
with her diplomacy and charming attitude
she basically brought light to every
room
however this is incredibly different
from her mother and her morals
as we see in the first film before her
character development
evie is completely brainwashed to
believe that the most important thing in
life is that she remains
the fairest of them all prince with a
big castle
and a mother-in-law wing something her
mother told would be vital in landing
that perfect husband
could her mother be projecting her past
mistakes when it comes to her love life
the mistakes
she might have made with evie's father
the evil queen also made sure that evie
was well equipped and everything that
would classify a woman as a
stereotypical housewife
i roll she mentions in the first film
that but i'm
i'm really good at sewing and cooking
and cleaning
you know like your mother cinderella how
else would she have the best outfits in
all the land
there is tons of speculation though that
evie was taught all of this from her
mother because her mother believes this
is what prevented her from finding or
better yet
keeping her true love i mean evie admits
that she isn't allowed to leave the
house without her mother approving her
appearance
talk about being strict when we follow
evie to auradon we also see that her
biggest goal at the academy
is to find a husband any chance he's in
line for a throne
anywhere in line while it could be that
it's the morals of her mother rubbing
off on her there's also a theory going
around that evie
might be seeking that male partnership
because of her lack of father figure
she even uses the magic mirror that her
mother gave her to find the wand
in order to impress doug the son of one
of the seven dwarfs
do you think that not growing up with a
father had a big impact on evie
towards the end of the film we do see
evie learn that there's more important
qualities she has other than her beauty
i guess i am kind of talented you are
definitely getting it
and we see her take on more of an
intellectual role especially when it
comes to chemistry
her quick change of heart though opens
up so many theories into who could
actually be her father
let's take a look at some theories that
might possibly blow you away
the most obvious theory is that maybe
evie's father
is just good old king leopold if we go
back to the original snow whitetail the
evil queen
is married to snow white's father also
known as
leopold while things turned dark in the
original tale with the evil queen
meeting her demise by falling off a
cliff
this obviously did not happen in the
world of the descendants
what if she was brainwashed to the isle
already pregnant with evie
it's totally possible i mean snow white
may be considered the fairest of them
all to the heroes but to the villains
evie was just as beautiful could the two
be half-sisters
maybe we can we do have to admit they
kind of do
look alike but because we don't have an
exact timeline it's kind of difficult to
tell
staying within the vibes of the world of
snow white we could also take a guess
that maybe
the traditional huntsman is her father
what's your majesty
the little princess while he never
succeeded in killing snow white he would
most likely be banished to the isle
alongside the evil queen and her
daughter
some might say that he was more than
just the queen's servant
in the abc disney series once upon a
time which also dealt on traditional
versions of our favorite disney
characters
the evil queen actually controlled the
huntsman and made him fall in love with
her
did the evil queen not also brainwash
evie into thinking that her beauty was
all that mattered
i mean that's a little darker than where
betting a disney channel movie would go
but it's definitely still a possibility
not to mention that one of the evil
queen's crimes for being sent to the
isle was actually manipulation
going off taking some inspiration from
the series once upon a time we can also
theorize that maybe
the evil queen was in love with someone
before being forced to marry
into royalty my gift to you
is this happy happy day
all of the descendants characters seem
to have untraditional backstories so
what if this was hers it wouldn't be
surprising for the evil queen to have
been in love with someone who didn't
return the same feelings and instead
used her
that would also explain her insecurities
when it comes to making sure her
daughter is chosen by a man to become
his wife and maybe it's the reason she's
so controlling as well
it's a super problematic theory but she
is a villain after all
luckily evie has realized her own
self-worth outside of her beauty
it would definitely make for an
interesting adventure for evie
what other villain could be her father
if we stray away from the traditional
snow white story even further and just
look at some of the traits evie has
it's super possible that her father
could actually be none other than beauty
and the beasts gaston
thank you all for coming to my wedding
first i better go in there and
propose to the girls the descendants is
after all heavily focused on that
classic tale with main character ben
being her son
it would definitely add to the drama
like gaston
evie is beautiful vain and not to
mention at times subconsciously selfish
this is the land of opportunity we can
be whatever we want to be here
you could argue that it was the way she
was raised but he is also a villain
which means he
would be on the isle and if you know
gaston he would definitely try to get
with the person who was rivaling to be
the fairest of them all
no matter if she wasn't snow white if we
think of evie's dad in relation to how
it can fit in a possible fourth part
there's one theory
that makes the most sense in the third
installment of the franchise
we all find out mal's father is actually
god of the underworld himself
hades he left when she was just a baby
but has since returned
no no i left your mother
in the film mal convinces hades to give
her his special ember
although she is only half a goddess she
cannot channel
all of the power his ember has however
when she attempts to use it
her hair mysteriously begins to change
from her classic purple to a dark blue
sound familiar who else has unusually
blue hair
that's right evie yes we're saying that
there just might be a possibility that
mal and evie are siblings
not only do they have the same blue hair
but their powers are similar
eevee also being considered the fairest
of them all makes sense in this theory
as well
gods are after all considered to be
traditionally beautiful when in
comparison to regular humans
if we take a closer look at mal and
evie's relationship
they also act way more like sisters than
they do best friends
don't give me the face put the powder
away
they're constantly annoyed with one
another they call each other out but in
the end
are each other's go-to when things take
a turn if you have a sister this kind of
relationship probably sounds familiar
in the descendants novels hades also has
another child
a son named haiti and his description is
weirdly
similar to evie's blue hair beautiful
self-centered
it doesn't get much more similar than
that looking at the relationship between
the evil queen and maleficent
it would also explain the tension they
had in the very first novel
it may not have been seen in the movies
but evie and her mother were actually
cursed to live by themselves in a castle
in the very depths of the isle after
maleficent banished them for not
inviting mao to evie's sixth birthday
but what if it was all a cover-up what
if maleficent
actually discovered that hades was
evie's father as well
it would make sense that the evil queen
was jealous of mal potentially becoming
more beautiful than her daughter because
they shared the same father
either way i think that we can all agree
banishment seems a little harsh for not
being invited to a birthday
the frustrating fact about all of these
theories is that there's a possibility
we may never know whether
any of them are even remotely correct
while there's been speculation about a
part 4
there's been no official announcement
with the tragic loss of cameron boyce in
2019
which would mean losing main character
carlos people have already counted the
next film out of the picture but
we're not giving up hope in an interview
last year dove cameron opened up about
her thoughts on a fourth film
while she did admit that it would feel
weird continuing the franchise without
cameron
it's definitely not out of the question
i don't know
anything but i definitely don't think
that that's like an impossibility
she admitted that things might have to
happen in a different incarnation though
sophia carson who plays evie also said
that she's not sure what the future
holds for the descendants franchise
it's a difficult subject but um who
knows who else the future holds who
knows the future holds
but definitely thinks that there could
be more story to tell it was also
revealed back in march 2020 that the
films would be getting a broadway show
so could that be our ticket to finding
out the truth once and for all
there has yet to be any casting
announcements and we'll admit that it'll
probably be a little odd to see other
actors playing our favorite descendants
but it could definitely be a good way to
clear out any unanswered questions
guess we'll just have to wait and see
whoever evie's father is
he is no doubt just as epic as she is
what if he isn't even a villain
that would be a huge plot twist what do
you think about mal and evie potentially
being half sisters
do you think that we'll get all of these
answers in a hypothetical part 4
let us know all of your magical opinions
in the comments section below
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and give this video a like if
you're rooting for a fourth film
until next time
you